[Music]
thank you
Hello friends and thank you for watching
and for allowing us to come to you with
this program I would like to know it is
a blessing for us to share this time
together answering the questions the
inquiries that you may have sent and we
are thankful to the Lord that it gives
us the opportunity to interact with you
and your questions and allow us to
answer thoroughly from the word of God I
Am David Salazar and with me are two
distinguished speakers of course to my
left Pastor Stephen Bohr a blessing to
have you here pastor with us it's always
a great blessing to work with both of
you it's a blessing to have you and to
my right Pastor CA who we have missed
for a few months and I know he's been
busy working and ministering for the
Lord thank you Pastor for coming and
being with us again here it is good to
be back and as I said I'm glad you
didn't say vacation because it was not a
victim but I missed this particular
program and others too but I like this
program and it's always fun to study the
word of God together absolutely and
thank you for allowing us to come to
your office to your home wherever you
are with the questions that we are going
to answer today and remember to send
your questions or inquiries to TV at
some
tv.org that is TV at some tv.org answer
send your questions your inquiries and
by the grace of God we'll do the best we
can to answer them in due time and
before we start we would like to invite
the presence of God so allies Pastor CA
if you can lead us into the word of God
of prayer shall we pray gracious father
how we praise you and thank you for your
word which is truly a lamp unto our feet
and a light that shines brightly on the
path before us if we what open that word
and study it and grow from it so father
we ask that you would be the center and
circumference of all that we say this
day may your thoughts be our thoughts
may your word come forth with new
Clarity and new power may we be blessed
uh this day and may those who sit and
consume what we have to offer be
likewise blessed and encourage as
together we walk the road that leads to
Glory we praise you and thank you in
Jesus name amen amen well as we you know
know we see the questions that you sent
to us and we have a wonderful question
to start this today's program from
brother Mark Clark and the question is
from
from him that he comes from the island
of Barbados but currently sites in Dubai
and so the question he has for us is the
following he says I have learned quite a
lot from secrets and sealed and I myself
do Bible studies with friends family and
colleagues as I do my part to spread the
Three Angels messages in these last days
of Earth's history this is the purpose
of my question I have been studying
Jeremiah 25 Revelation 20 Ezekiel 38 and
39 as well as Joel 3 looking at the
final destruction of the wicked and I
have a question primarily relating to a
singular 39 I understand that at the
second coming the Thousand Years
commences Satan is bound the righteous
are in heaven and the dead remain dead
after this the wicked are resurrected
the New Jerusalem comes down to be set
down in the valley created when the
Mount of Olives is Split in Two and
Satan leads the wicked to come against
the city but in the process there all
destroyed and Satan and his sympathizers
are no more however this is where I am
confused following on from Ezekiel 39
9-21 dealing with after the wicked are
destroyed in mentions about the Saints
using the weapons left by the wicked to
be used as fuel for seven years and for
seven months the Saints shall be burying
the wicked
it further goes on to talk about the
birds in the flesh this is all a bit
confusing for me but I know that God is
not the author of confusion I was of the
opinion that the great sacrifice for the
birds was before the Thousand Years
Revelation 19 17-21 could you therefore
please shed some light on the above
points uh in Secretary nine as mentioned
above so the question is in regards to
Ezekiel 39 and I think that I want to
you know first of all kind of honor our
friend Mark who's studying the
scriptures and I'm glad that he's been a
student of the scriptures trying to
understand one verse one another but uh
let's see pastors what do you think
about the question that he has is a very
interesting train of thought that he's
following what are the question or how
we can answer him and point him in the
right direction you know before we begin
we were talking just a little bit
because we we study the word of God but
we study independently but it's amazing
how we we've Fallen the same text in our
minds are are aligned on so much of this
and that's because the word of God is
one you know if you're studying with
sincerity you're going to line up with
someone who's also studying with
sincerity I'd like to mention my dad was
born in Barbados he is a vegan and I've
been there many times and and done
meetings and not a big island but the
Adventist Church is doing very very well
in Barbados it's a wonderful little
island there in the East Caribbean
heading towards Trinidad and Tobago
really really nice nice little island
I've been to husband St James which is
the birthplace of my dad amen a couple
things come up when we um look at at a
lot of the texts in Ezekiel Ezekiel some
of the texts in Isaiah that have dual
applications that have a direct
application to the people to whom it was
written and a secondary application uh
down towards the end of time uh an
eschatological shall we say application
right one of the things that uh we do in
looking at these uh texts is
the realization that in every aspect of
the text they don't line up as far as
that secondary application is preserved
is is concerned so you will see aspects
that apply to the people at the time you
will see aspects that apply to uh the
time prior to the second coming but in
every particular aspect you won't find a
parallel now we know there is there is a
commonality because we see Gog and Magog
in both in both but the
seven years the seven months simply does
not fit and that is why you have to
study the Bible line upon a line here a
little a little they're little because
you will find places where it just
doesn't make sense it just doesn't fit
so it simply does not apply at that at
that particular point I think that
that's right pastor and I think that is
important to remember that in
eschatology for for our understanding
there are really two books that are
really one was actually sealed which was
Daniel seal for the time of the end and
Revelation was given for us to
understand rightly so the end time
events
I'm sorry that will happen in the end of
time therefore these are the two real
books that we need to use as a reference
point where these are the ones that lead
us and any other details from other
prophets or or like you mentioned
certain certain uh
prophecies or that can have dual
interpretation in the application are
really just
I side notes that support the overview
of Daniel Revelation that are the ones
that are really for us to understand a
lot of the uh you know Sunday churches
and Sunday preachers use verses in
Ezekiel to sort of support their ideas
for a way you know out of line concept
of end time events Adventist Church does
not because the Lord revealed us very
clearly what book was to be understood
and uh really be cleared on prophecies
for the end time events which is Daniel
Revelation and I also the British
secretary nine for example as you were
mentioning it has some has some words
that link us to Revelation but it's not
really about the end of the world or the
end of the wicked but more so applying
to Israel in the literal sense you know
I gotta love my friend Pastor board
because he said he was not going to talk
too much during this program but I see
him that he's itching he's itching to
say something he's taking notes
vociferously so go ahead Pastor War
we're going to lose you and let you go
man because you can't help yourself
I'm chomping up a bit precisely
yeah um actually the Book of Revelation
globalizes
what we find in the Old Testament that
applied to literal Israel
a couple of examples
in the Book of Joel which is mentioned
in the question right it speaks about
the valley of Jehoshaphat
which is outside Jerusalem
but in Revelation chapter 14 the same
scene
where Joel says the Harvest in the
valley of Jehoshaphat is ripe
in Revelation 14 it says the Harvest of
the earth is right yes so what was local
becomes a symbol of what is global at
the end of time
in the Old Testament deals with literal
Israel at the end it deals with global
spiritual Israel and that's the
principle we need to apply
in the Old Testament you have the enemy
coming from the north
Gog from the land of Magog comes from
the north right but in Revelation
chapter 20 verses 8 and 9 it says it
comes Gog and mega come from the four
corners of the Earth from everywhere so
in other words it's globalized in the
Book of Revelation what is found that
applied locally now the same terminology
many times is used in The Book of
Revelation
but all of the details that apply to
literal Israel do not necessarily apply
at the end of time you have to take the
perspective of Revelation as being a
fuller revelation
you know like for example we're going to
be burying the dead for months or years
you know that doesn't fit with Jeremiah
25 which is describing that the Earth is
going to be desolate the bodies of the
wicked are going to be laying on the
surface of the Earth it doesn't fit with
Jeremiah 4 which is talking about the
Earth being without form and void and
the heavens not having light so when the
Book of Revelation draws upon the Old
Testament
every detail of the type does not for is
not parallel to what happens in the
enter type for example and I don't
intend to be irreverent by saying this
um you know Jesus is symbolized by a
lamb but Jesus is not a woolly creature
with four legs correct so many of the
details don't apply what applies the
general principle yes that as the lamb
the sin was placed on the head of the
lamb and then the lamb was slain by The
Sinner that applies but not necessarily
all of the details so that's the
principle that we have to apply when we
take these prophecies in the Old
Testament and apply them spiritually and
globally in the future yeah yeah well
said and I think it's important that
because if you try to apply every
particular point you will get yourself
spiritually confused and that's what
he's saying God is an author of
confusion well some points simply don't
fit uh and if you try to make them fit
you will sort of get off track
thank you and and I think it's important
that we encourage uh our friends to to
study to continue to study is I I enjoy
seeing people that are certain
scriptures and comparing scripture with
the scripture is important to do that
but at the end of the day also
remembered that you know we need to have
these principles of interpretation that
have to be applied so we don't go off in
a wrong uh and or you know in a wrong
direction okay so now we go to the next
question and uh let's go and this is
from Lucky who comes or sends us from
Nigeria the question and is the
following question
it says I thank our bless Jesus and I
pray for his sustain sustenance of this
program its benefits are far-reaching
please I want to know if Forex Trading
is based on the same Principle as
gambling so Gentlemen let's see what is
the answer what could you say about this
interview pastors well I think maybe
what we need to do first of all is
explain what Forex Trading is correct
because to be honest with you when I
read this question I didn't have the
four years 90 of what Forex Trading was
uh so but I did some research so here is
a definition that we find online the
Foreign Exchange Market is where
currencies are traded
a currency exchange this International
Market's most unique aspect is that it
lacks a central Marketplace kind of like
the stock market
instead currency trading is conducted
electronically over the counter this
means that all transactions occur via
computer networks among Traders
worldwide rather than on one centralized
exchange like the stock market exchange
so that's what trading is now is uh
Forex Trading the same as gambling
gambling that's the question
well I don't know if that really is in
the same league as gambling because
gambling really is about you know
trying your best to have luck I guess or
you know just counting odds or whatnot
but in this case Forex I had a friend
who really spent a lot of time
researching or doing his studying in
Forex and he was telling me that it was
because I had the same questions like
isn't the same thing as gambling I will
ask him and he said no he's not you have
to do a lot of uh studying do a lot of
Investigation you know and and really
learn how markets work what currencies
are are are a good invest and that kind
of thing and so and he said he has
ultimately there's a level of luck I
suppose but most of it is really
research that you have to do to be able
to be successful in this venue and it's
not something that you invest uh you
know little to gain a lot you know it's
really more so of little uh increments
and and gains you know as you as you go
through your Investments
um I will say that I don't think the
same way I don't see it as the same way
I don't particularly endorse anybody
going into into these things you know I
think this is something that if somebody
wants to study or get involved in it
they have to really see for themselves
is something that they want to do I
think there are better ways to earn
money more you know through you know
applying your your strength your talents
but if somebody feels like Forex is a
way for them to gain an Investments I
suppose it's up to them you know I
really don't know but I don't see them
exactly as gambling
the question was asked is it based on
the same Principle as gambling I think
the answer is no gambling is based on
the principle that a lot of people have
to lose for somebody to win that's the
only way you get that big pot we're all
putting in most of us are never going to
see that money again
one person will win or a small group of
people Forex is not based on that I mean
the the church has money in certain
stocks uh and there's a science to
getting into the stock market when they
sell one to hold those kinds of things I
see Forex more in that vein as opposed
to gambling money which is almost
assuredly you're you're going to lose
even if you start out with something
you'll probably lose that too right yeah
I found in the research that I did that
you know gambling is that you buy a
lottery ticket and you hope you win and
someone else's money that they invested
in I guess you shouldn't say invested
but spent right
um but for Forex uh trading according to
what I was able to find
um it takes research
it takes looking at Trends right in in
the value of the currencies it takes
into account
projections future projections also the
financial status of the countries that
you're dealing in their currency so
there's a certain a certain discipline
right a certain process that needs to be
followed in order to make money in the
Forex exchange whereas with gambling you
simply buy the lottery ticket and you
hope that you're going to win right
right so I think is is really a good
answer what we have been able to share I
guess we all think I like in the sense
nevertheless we're not sponsoring
somebody to Adventure into those things
I think it's important that we also made
that clear you know if somebody wants to
follow uh because they feel that it's
important for them it's fine but it's
not something that we can necessarily
see and it's not really a Biblical
answer to this either so but we thank
you for sending us the question lucky
although that's I think thing too
so yeah lucky sent us the question about
whether it's the same to gamble yeah it
is in Forex Trading interesting
interesting all right so we have the
next question and uh from Bulgaria
Philip sends us this question and it's
the following if sin is a choice not a
state
like original sin or the idea how is God
going to judge babies and children which
have died prior to being able to have
the knowledge of what his sin is
and respectively choose to accept Christ
if God Saves them to Paradise because
they did not have the knowledge of to
choose wouldn't they go to heaven
without the merits of Christ if God
punishes them because they have not not
chosen Christ wouldn't God be unjust
because they were not able to make their
own choice for Assumption of guilt so
this is a question that Philip from
Bulgaria sends us but um what what are
the answers on this question I think we
have answered some of something similar
to this before but what can we say to
him I want to back into this
a certain way uh and then I'll let you
you guys sort of look at it and then
come back
if anyone gets into heaven
they get through through the merits of
Jesus Christ right right Christ opened
at the door there would be no way to get
into heaven without the sacrifice of
Christ
so if anyone gets in it's because of
Christ's sacrifice yeah
um so if God gives credit to a baby who
does not know what they're doing
uh it's still through Jesus because
there simply is no other way to get into
heaven without Christ
[Music]
and that's corroborated by scripture
acts 4 verse 12 nor is there salvation
in any other yes for there is no other
name under Heaven given among men by
which we must be saved so
be it as it may
no one will be saved outside of Jesus
Christ precisely right right yeah
Christian is a very exclusive religion
it's it's rather bigoted you know it's
Christ yes only Christ always Christ no
other way but Christ no there's certain
Bible verses that I think will help
because the Bible does say that sin is
when you knowingly choose
uh when you've reached the age of
accountability uh and there are several
texts that we could read uh you know
First John 3 verse 4 is the most famous
yes
um whoever commits sin is a transgress
of the law for sin is the transgression
of the law
and Ellen White states that that's the
only definition of sin in the Bible
um
she in the book faith and works page 56
she wrote now we want to understand what
sin is
then it is the transgression of God's
law this is the only definition given in
the scriptures
and also uh James 4 verse 17 which
clearly expresses the same principles uh
James 4 verse 17 says therefore to him
who knows yes right so you have to be
cognizant who knows to do good and does
not do it to him it is sin and the Bible
defines what is good right so you have
to have knowledge which means that
you're not held guilty because you
inherit a sinful nature you're held
guilty when you respond knowingly yes to
that sinful nature yes that James 4 17
is the one that sort of locks it down
for me it it it it it puts out the
central at the center of the controversy
knowledge yeah and once having known one
chooses not to yeah exactly settles it
for me so if so if they have not reached
the age of accountability then they
cannot be held accountable correct right
right
now the question you know he's implying
is will the Lord save the babies because
they were not
they couldn't make a choice or a child
there's a statement from Ellen White
that that answers that question that
indicates that correct uh the book
Heaven page 45
she's speaking about the resurrection at
the end as the little infants what is an
infant
a baby
a baby yeah toddler as the little
infants come forth Immortal from their
Dusty beds they immediately Wing their
way to their mother's arms
they meet again never more to part
so are there babies that are going to be
taken to Heaven absolutely yes they'll
be taken to their mother's arms then it
says but many of the little ones have no
mother there yes so there's got to be
infants that are going to have it Go to
Heaven that their mother was not saved
yeah so once again but many of the
little ones have no mother there we
listen in vain for the rapturous song of
Triumph from the mother
the Angels received the motherless
infants and conduct them to the Tree of
Life
very very interesting statement
[Music]
now will you know that that gives us I
believe a very clear answer as far as
babies in heaven that have non-knowledge
of sin yes through the marriage of
Christ only now will every single baby
be saved we don't know that either you
know it doesn't it doesn't assume that
or doesn't say that right so I have to
you know we have to be careful we can
only say the Lord knows those details
and I believe that we have to be very
careful with you know presenting an
absolute uh you know answer on this
question because there's no real
definite answer but what we do know is
children little babies infants that have
been you know the parents faithful they
will be reunited with their parents and
there will be babies that will not have
any parents there
um now the other question he said uh if
God punishes them because they have not
just in Christ well again that doesn't
really answer that's not really the the
answer we gave him because as we
mentioned
those babies there will be babies in
heaven that are not you know have not
had the chance to know the Christ or the
or the knowledge of the evil no one of
the things I'm sorry no go ahead one of
the things that we talked about in our
previous program is that during the
Thousand Years we'll be able to look
over some of this stuff and ratify that
God made a right judgment one thing
stands out God is not trying to keep
anybody out of Heaven he's trying to get
everybody in you know and save them uh
under you know the Aegis of the law is
not trying to go around it so um uh if
if babies get into heaven uh praise God
you know if I make it in praise God you
know I just I want everybody to get in
who can I'm not I'm not discriminating
against anybody I want them all to get
in and if and if babies get in through
the grace and the merits of Jesus Christ
and the grace of God well then praise
the Lord yeah two things that I'd like
to say first of all the statement by
Ellen White clearly says that there will
be babies infants there
whose mothers are not there no not there
which means that their mothers were not
saved
but the babies were saved
so so in other words there will be
parents that are lost but the babies
will be there yes so if the babies are
there
it's because they didn't they they had
not reached the age of accountability
right
so so maybe we could assume that babies
that have not reached the age of
accountability uh maybe God is going to
take them there the bottom line is this
that any decision that God makes
we will agree that it was the right
decision amen that God was just and
loving in the way that he dealt with
each case many times we try to explain
from this side yeah you know all the
ends and all the outs you know I just
want to make it there and once once we
get there we'll say you know we'll ask
the questions and Jesus will answer say
oh that makes all the sense in the world
you did it the right way so God doesn't
say
answer everything now he says trust me
and someday I'll give you the answer
precisely absolutely yeah and and there
is a aspect of the justice of God that
you know he even had examples in the Old
Testament where he will make their the
children of Israel go and destroy it
annihilate completely you know wipe out
certain groups individuals even little
children so things like those questions
that come up during this type of
thinking will really be thoroughly
answered by God who has the ultimate
understanding of knowledgeable things
from the end from the beginning and
therefore we have to trust that he's
answered or that he does the right thing
and we will get those questions or
answers to the questions there we
shouldn't ask why we should simply trust
amen that God's way is the best way but
in order for that to happen we have to
know God as being trustworthy and we
know him through his word yeah man yes
those questions are are of Doubt usually
come from Minds that are not settled
with the Lord once you trust the Lord
and have worked with the Lord and have
him work with you and you've tested it
and try him you know that you can trust
him that's one of the first things that
gets settled once you give your heart to
the Lord he is trustworthy amen yeah
amen well we thank you again for joining
us on this program we pray that the
blessings of the Lord will continue to
lead you and guide in your life may God
bless you and hope to see you next time
foreign
[Music]